la crise des opioïdes défraie les
manchettes depuis les dernières années
voilà qu'on apprend dans un nouveau
rapport de santé publique canada que
l'espérance de vie des canadiens
pourraient diminuer à cause de cette
crise en 2010 est seulement près de 4000
canadiens sont morts des suites d'une
surdose ce qui équivaut à 11 décès par
jour
alors j'en parle avec alain poirier
médecin conseil à l'institut national de
santé publique du québec et professeur
en santé publique qu'on soit radin
poirier la merci de cette collaboration
qu'on va renouveler chaque fois que cela
est nécessaire pour comprendre les
enjeux de santé publique écouter on
apprenait des morts ici par koudou dans
les provinces à l'autre mais notre 4000
mans en 2017 et que ça pourrait ces
chiffres la faire diminuer la première
fois l'espérance de vie c'est très
inquiétant non oui et non je commençais
par le oui évidemment c'est des décès
évitables complètement et quand
l'immense population plus jeune donc
dans le calcul fictif ce que c'est que
l'espérance de vie c'est à la naissance
en 2018
80000 l'essence au québec on applique la
mortalité de chaque tranche d'âge plus
on dit quand est ce que quelqu'un qui
naîtrait cette année quand est-ce que
50% seront décidés donc en ce moment ses
80 années pour les hommes au québec et
84 les femmes
donc à partir du moment où dans une
tranche d'âge plus jeune comme celles
qu'ont connues britannique présentement
il ya beaucoup de décès mais si on
applique les 17 cette année à ceux qui
n'a et serena colombie-britannique leur
espérance de vie est plus courte
on dit pour est parce qu elle vienne
asselah qui en a le plus le sien de 20
fois plus proportionnellement parlant en
colombie-britannique coq au québec qu'on
est là la province où en est loin mais
ce sont des décès évitables et des décès
qui arrive chez les plus jeunes donc oui
ça l'est un impact sur le calcul
statistique de l'âge où on peut espérer
vie donc ça nous préoccupe
mais c'est des petits chiffres quand
même 16 du chiffre et il ya des moyens
évidemment c'est fictif parce qu'on voit
le j'espère qu'on va juguler cette crise
depuis le nombre des décès donc on
espère que ces chiffres ne
s'appliqueront pas 80 warned souvent
dicté à cause de l'abus de près de
nantes
description sommaire à ce qu'on pensait
qu'on s'est beaucoup le fentanyl c'est
illégal c'est un marché illégal de ces
api rio une augmentation de la
prescription en amérique du nord de
façon générale quoique dans les
dernières années ça s'est calmé pour des
raisons assez clair on enseigne de plus
amples mieux contrôler la douleur ce
sont des molécules qui font ça
maintenant il ya lieu quand même de
revoir le niveau de prescription les
alternatives pour pas que ce soit la
source principale dans les dernières
années
évidemment si on a participé comme
médecins à une forme de dépendance
quand les gens soient qu'ils n'en n'ont
plus de prescrits ils entrent ou jeu le
marché noir et sur le marché noir
le ya ce fameux fontanil qui lui qui est
beaucoup plus puissant et eu beaucoup de
des gens donc dans les surdoses
d'opioïdes ya de grands pas en mettant
ses pédales et on apprend que ce camp
sera par là que si pour les jeunes en
tout cas son addition l'alcool le tabac
et les opioïdes la fin d'année ça coûte
30 milliards de dollars en coûts de
santé en justice pénale est en perte de
productivité
c'est non effectivement et ces trois là
sont de beaucoup supérieur ou cannabis -
il avait sonné de l'ordre de 2 milliards
pour toutes ces catégories qu'on voit à
l'écran ce moment est la plus grande
partie la majorité de ces frais dans le
cas du cannabis c'est justement le
fameux justice pénale donc à l'intérieur
des objectifs de santé publique qui est
de ne pas criminaliser ne pas faire de
justice mais mais on l'a toujours dit
les autres produits comme l'alcool et le
tabac sont légaux et en termes de
fardeaux ici on a vu le fardeau
économique pas seulement soins de santé
mais en perte de productivité les frais
de justice tout ça explique beaucoup
plus de milliards que le cannabis dont
on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers crient
maintenant script est aussi de notre
surprise inquiétante c'est l'abus
d'alcool chez les jeunes
les jeunes développent des comportements
excessifs dangereux avec l'alcool comme
excessif quand ils font du binge
drinking les à bulles en une seule fois
mais aussi donc on dit qu'après 25 % de
la population ou des consommations qui
pose des problèmes donc chez les jeunes
cette consommation abusive plus de cinq
consommations en une seule fois donc le
niveau de problèmes d'abus d'alcool chez
les jeunes étaient autour de 20% dans le
tabac ils sont happés par jour
quotidiennement il ya un problème
donc c'est 20 % pour la tabasser 13 dans
le cas du cannabis et 2 3 pour ça donc
on voit bien que encore là les deux aux
catégories de produit légalement sont
consommés de façon plus régulière et ont
des impacts sur la santé fort
significatif alors comment on fait pour
prévenir ça d'ailleurs plusieurs mesures
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les mesures
sont actuellement semblables d'une
molécule à l'autre des problèmes à l'eau
kelly il ya quatre grandes catégories et
lieu toujours et l'administratif en chef
dans son rapport commence toujours par
les mesures sur la réduction des
inégalités sociales les logements les
régions de la pauvreté qui sont les
grands facteurs de sociétés des
catégories comme ça dans notre
communauté et individuellement et dans
notre famille donc des facteurs et des
des solutions d intervention à toutes
ces catégories de gier de
d'environnement on a sans doute
banaliser la consommation d'alcool c'est
sympathique c'est convivial et caetera
et face aux jeunes on n'a peut-être pas
agi avec assez de sérieux peut-être face
à l'alcool
en fait si on a déjà essayé de prohiber
savez dans ce cas là aussi pas donner de
bons résultats que pour plusieurs îles
passionnel que c'est moins pire que le
cannabis par exemple ce soir et c'est
toute la société tous les niveaux et
dans ce cas là y'a même pas un gradient
par rapport à pauvreté même les
populations les plus favorisés
consomment parfois plus que les les
défavorisés mais dans chacune des
molécules dont on parle des enjeux de
société mais il est en jeu aussi de
commercialisation jusqu'à quelle quel
prix on donne
est ce que c'est vraiment que c'est si
facilement tout le temps donc on a fait
beaucoup beaucoup sur le tabac mais pas
vraiment sur l'alcool réactions sur la
volonté de la chine d'aller de l'avant
avec la vingtaine c'est pas une bonne
idée sur le point de vue médical oui à
plus de riches et les jeunes de psychose
mais c'est la mesure c'est ne pas de
passer de 18 à 21 avant c'était 119 ans
où s'était permise parce que ça ne
l'était pas mais de la menaient 21 à
sanair auriez si la contrepartie c'est
que quand on pense qu'on va banaliser au
lycée on a une neuro pédiatre qui
devrait de capable de faire l'éducation
est en position privilégiée sur
clairement exposé lui qui est venu en
affaire qui va écouter des gens
commissions parlementaires y compris
l'association des pis car on en a vu
avec vous la semaine dernière qui ont
changé d'idée là dessus sur l'âge il
pensait que c'était une bonne idée
compte tenu des risques individuels
connu mais ça ne l'est pas eh bien merci
beaucoup alain paré